[Applause]
it's October 4th 2018 the heat from the
arena lights shine bright and the Tigers
new head coach
it's a coronation for the prodigal son
of Memphis but for Penny Hardaway this
moment the gang years ago with a wish
from a dying friend they became a closer
knit basketball team would penny
coaching but they knew all the time they
was doing the Phinehas and it gave them
to thrive to uh the will they wanted to
win for Desmond
in the Binghampton area it was tough
because you had gangs negative things
going on in the neighborhood and you had
to be really strong not to to be a part
of those negative things I think he is
growing up in Memphis it was different
generations I grew up in the era where
around my family there was hustlers
advantage balls to the to the life of
street life you know I'm saying like
negative activity hood life you know
that a lot of people unfortunately can't
get around because they born in these
situations
[Music]
Penny Hardaway was raised in Binghamton
a neighborhood east of downtown Memphis
a few doors down live Desmond
Merriweather as the two grew older they
forged what will become a lifelong
basketball bond right here on these
courts by Lester middle school we were
probably maybe 10 11 12 years old
somewhere in there and we were in the
park and I just knew Desmond he was
really competitive huge personality a
happy-go-lucky guy and lovely laugh but
when it came to competing he was it will
fight you too I mean he will fight you
honestly I could beat I got to come back
I got to get revenge on theirs now he's
small but he got a mouth they have a
very competitive even though he was
small in stature and he would push pin
it because he was saying you're bigger
than me you're stronger than me can you
take me made me tougher I didn't want to
lose either it didn't matter if he was
smaller or not I wasn't gonna you know
play him tough and didn't take it easy
on him he didn't want anybody to take it
easy on him so it helped multiplets
penny will go on to start at the high
school collegiate and for you
[Applause]
des played four years at land college in
Jackson Tennessee after graduating he
returned to their childhood neighborhood
to coach the less-than middle school
team the same middle school that both
des and any attendant there's no two
children he I think he wanted to rush
colleges but as he could just so he
could get back here to coach the
children I know his coach got played
hard to play for can't be so gay baby
went to a while for me he hates to he
gives up his own so he's a thanks to
every time he wasn't just teaching
basketball he was teaching morals and
standards the children really felt
united and together and they had a
purpose and once they got to win in the
children everything they they behavior
changed but just as the team started to
thrive des his health began to decline
one day he stopped by nowadays has lost
a lot of weight
he said I have colon cancer I just
passed out he was like mom wake up
please get up he looked at me and he
said mom you know I can't believe this I
am a person that do for everybody
anybody and he said me why me you know
so we sit there and we hooked one
another we both cried but the council
came along the pain but they still
worked with it in games I could tell
through his facial expression and stuff
but a lot of people in orders and stuff
didn't know what he was going through
but he was struggling to make it he went
through multiple surgeries the second
surgery he wanted some paper and he
struggled on the paper once and I was
like one sent so Marty said are you
referring about penny he couldn't speak
because he was on the ventilator he
thumb stopped and said call was it
because he wanted him to Oh sick as he
was he wanted penny to coach the team
four and that's what he was thinking
about I needed somebody that he knew he
can trust and knew that not only would
he knew that penny would teach them more
than just basketball his wife called me
and said that Desmond was in the
hospital and they had given him 48 hours
to live I mean he didn't have any signs
or if he did he didn't tell anyone about
it and it went from no signs to going
into the hospital
and a routine check-up to see what was
going on - you know like a stage-four
cancer he smiled when he saw me come in
and I kept standing him look man let's
get you well and we'll get to the
basketball and like nah man I'm telling
you my middle school team we're really
good and he said - you're the only guy
that can save our neighborhood and
that's why I told them to call you dad's
recovered and penny kept his pledge
staying to help des coach Leicester
middle school even though the team was
excelling the kids were still being
exposed to the same dangers that penny
and des faced during their childhoods
the same thing goes on the day is just
it's faster because of the internet is
because of the way the world's shifting
with social media so kids can also get
exposed to a lot of things way early and
so low and not having to be directly in
the household with back then if you went
directly with it you when exposed to you
heard about it now you can be directly
exposed to it indirectly Danny banging
Joe Dylan fight another time killing
it's not a fight how do you run around
gunshots see it uh kaaba's Jean I'm
sorry I can't cut another police it
might go back and look at it I said des
knew the territory of bank politics
would always be a day-to-day struggle a
challenge he'd met head-on when I first
got there there are a couple kids that
were in gangs and it was distracting
them - felt that they were going to get
injured or killed so he went to the gang
leaders and said hey you know you see
these kids from the basketball team call
me they're not supposed to be here we
don't want them here we want to get them
a different path and we're going in a
different direction we don't want them
to be a part of this game everybody
loved him he has so much respect and
love from around the neighborhood that
they they granted him their wish with
the players protected penny and des
coach Lester little school - three state
championships the basketball team helped
him because he was living through the
kids he didn't know how much time he had
but he knew his love for those children
and wanting to see them succeed would
help prolong his life and indeed Sunday
February 8th 2015
penny got a text message that he knew
one day was coming
they texted me and said hey get to the
house you know he's he's dying and went
to the house right out the church and as
I was going through the door he was
trying to speak did kind of like not to
see it up to tell to tell Nick that he
loved him and uh they ain't penny came
that's 60 words he still was trying to
you know hold his head up to look up to
nothing at the beer to tell me love I
can understand that he told me that you
know he loved me back and then all of a
sudden it just went blank he just went
to deep breaths
and then it was over like his I just
witnessed that like saying that I love
you he said he loved me and then he just
took two deep deep breaths and then it
just
man I couldn't I couldn't believe I'll
never witnessed anything like that
especially from a loved one someone that
I cared about to be able to witness that
and to see what he had gone through up
until that point it was almost like half
of me was really sad and other half was
he's not in pain anymore
Desmond Meriwether died at the age of 41
the city of Memphis still mourns his
loss
the grassroots basketball movement des
generated will be felt for generations
spawning some of the top high school and
collegiate players in the nation in our
neighborhood he was the man you know
everybody knew that he loved our
neighborhood and he wanted to to do well
he said our neighborhood needed a lift
he gave his heart he gave his soul and
his body and his life to those kids
you
what's up you guys it's Taylor Brooks
with bleach to report make sure that you
subscribe for more video content